c'est un sujet majeur qui doit faire
l'objet de choix politiques forts bons
femme dans la famille il ya quand même
des jacobins et ya quand même des
girondins au sens de la décentralisation
moi je vais vous donner mon point de vue
et je vous demanderai de trancher ce
point de vue première chose je
n'accepterai jamais le scandaleux
découpage territorial qui a été réalisé
par monsieur hollande et son
gouvernement
première chose je n'ai jamais vu en 35
ans un découpage aussi profondément
malhonnête et orienter vers des choix
politiciens
deuxièmement et chantant ce qu'a dit
nathalie s'agit pas de faire la
restauration mais quand on a eu des
bonnes idées c'est pas la peine
d'essayer de réinventer le fil à couper
le beurre
je vous avais proposé le conseiller
territorial et la fusion des
départements et des régions
je vous proposerai de reprendre ce
projet du causse et territoires entre
nous je me suis assez battu cher
christian pour le faire accepter par les
députés les nôtres et les sénateurs
aujourd'hui on voit bien que le
conseiller territorial c'était la
réponse
j'ajoute pour les cellules de la
ruralité que le jour vous supprimez le
conseiller général départemental
vous n'avez plus de représentants des
territoires les républicains ne peuvent
pas accepter la suppression du canton
même s'il voit ces rejets troisième
chose on va dire le plus compliqué les
grandes régions naturelles manque là on
a été élu celui qui sait pas tuer ou
celle qui s'est battu pour être élu il
va pas proposer de ré de rendre une
région dans le même temps quand je vois
la région rhône alpes auvergne
une logique implacable d'aurillac à val
d'isère
huit heures de voiture quand je vois
languedoc-roussillon midi-pyrénées 13
départements
je trouve que dans le projet
d'alternance qui sera l'hôte vont
proposer à chacune de ces grandes
régions de dialoguer avec le
gouvernement pour voir celles qui
continuent ou celles qui veulent revenir
à la situation antérieure
et c'est pas fort c'est que ça soit la
même réponse
je pense à nous à viana siens
pour qui j'ai moi même pris des
engagements mais vous voyez un débat
chéramy de la marne où dans chaque rue
grande région on déciderait
tranquillement entre le pouvoir central
est pouvoir régional la région de
jean-pierre poitou charentes limousin
aquitaine c'est grand comme l'autriche
est ce qu ils veulent continuer ensemble
ou est-ce qu'il veut revenir à notre
découpage il n'y a pas une réponse
unique de mon point de vue
dernier point en m'excusant des trop
long mais c'est pour essayer d'être
précis parce que c'est un débat je vous
proposerai tranché la sphère du rsa le
rsa a été une réussite comme lutte
contre la pauvreté a été un échec comme
instrument d'insertion faut dire les
choses comme elles sont moi ma réponse à
titre personnel et je vous proposerai un
débat sur le sujet c'est de fusionner en
une seule allocations rsa prime
d'activité allocation personnelles au
logement
une seule allocation permettrait de
mettre de la transparence et de lutter
contre les fraudes en mettant comme
condition l'acceptation d'un emploi
d'une formation
sinon on court la location unique
vous pouvez le faire avec la location
unique vous ne pouvez pas faire avec la
multiplicité des allocations est de mon
point de vue ami de la maman m'avait pas
dit votre prénom
apple rappelle je suis plutôt pour un
transfert à l'état de cette allocation
unique plutôt qu'une gestion par les
départements qui ne peuvent pas gérer
financièrement et politiquement c'est
cette allocation
voilà vous voyez c'est ça l'intérêt de
nos débats je vous dis pas que j'ai
raison je vous dis pas que c'est la
ligne du mouvement
je vous dis que ça fait partie rappel
des grands débats que je souhaite
qu'avec eric qu'avec laurent qu'avec
l'équipe de direction nous soumettions à
votre vote
si un peu au dollar en fait du programme
de gouvernement
ce sont des grandes orientations
stratégiques